the grand theft auto trilogy definitive
edition is now out so of course we gotta
compare it to the original versions so
here is a look comparing the definitive
versions running on the xbox series x
to the original xbox releases and yes i
know the xbox versions are slightly
different to the ps2 versions but it's
what i had if you enjoyed this
comparison make sure to give us a like
and sub and stay tuned to gamespot for
more coverage on all things video games
[Music]
sorry babe i'm an ambitious girl
you're just a small time
liberty city is in shock today as the
police and emergency services deal with
the aftermath of a devastating attack on
a police convoy this morning as yet no
details have been released about the
prisoners being transferred in the
convoy and no group has claimed
responsibility the convoy left police
headquarters early this morning for a
routine transfer of felons to liberty
penitentiary the attack took place on
the callahan bridge leaving few
witnesses and the bridge itself severely
damaged some of the convicts are thought
to have perished in the explosion that
followed the initial attack revelations
as to the professionalism of the attack
struck police hours afterward when
identification of the missing felons
were further hampered by an attack by
computer hackers on police headquartered
databases with the porter tunnel project
falling behind schedule this disaster
leaves portland isolated from the rest
of the city
[Applause]
come on
saying your [ __ ]
it's no problem to kill you
you gonna be sorry
hi hi get lost
[Applause]
watch the curves
wait here man while i go in and talk to
luigi
eight balls got some business upstairs
well maybe you could do me a favor one
of my girls needs a ride so grab a car
and pick up misty from the clinic then
bring it back here remember no one
messes with my girls
so keep your hands on the wheel you
don't mess this up maybe to be more work
for you now get out of here
what are you doing
[Music]
joey
am i gonna get to play with your big
ends again i'll be with you in a minute
spark plug
hey i'm joey luigi said you were
reliable so come back later there might
be some work for you all right
i'm bored when you're gonna drill me in
a moment sweetheart i got a little
business to take care of
i got a little job for you pal the
pharrelli brothers have owed me money
for too long and they need to be taught
some respect
lips ferrelli is stuffing his fat face
in the saint mark's bistro so steal his
car and take it to eight balls bomb shop
up in harwood you know eight ball right
once he's fitted it with a bomb go park
the car where you found him then sit
back and watch the whole show but hurry
up he won't be in forever
marvel is great
[Music]
what you saying
hey hey guys it's uh ken rosenberg here
hey hey great hey well uh i'm gonna
drive you guys to the meet okay
now i've talked to the suppliers and
they are very uh keen to start a
business relationship so uh if all goes
well we should uh
be doing very nicely for ourselves which
is you know good
okay so they're brothers okay one
operates the uh the business and the
other one
okay that's them in the chopper all
right here's the deal they want a
straight exchange on open ground
all right
okay stay tight let's go
[Music]
[Music]
got it 100
pure grade a colombian my friend let me
say it the greens tens and twenties used
i think we have a deal my friend
oh [ __ ]
i don't need this
we interrupt your programming with a
message from the state department all
bridges and some roads in the vice city
metropolitan area have been closed
because of a severe weather warning
meteorologists are tracking from miami
doing time for the family is no piece of
cake but the family looks after its own
okay it's how'd the deal go down you
sitting on some white gold
look sonny we were set up the deal was
an ambush harry and lee are dead you
better be kidding me tommy tell me you
still got the money
no sonny
i don't have the money
that was my money tommy my money
you better not be schooled me tell me
because you know i'm not a man to be
screwed with wait sonny
you have my personal assurance and i'm
gonna get you your money back and the
drugs and i'm gonna mail you the dicks
of those responsible hey i already know
that you're not a fool tommy but i warn
you neither am i
this is a disaster we are so screwed man
these gorillas listen to me are gonna
come down here and rip my head off it's
ridiculous i did not go to law school
for this okay now what the hell are we
gonna do
shut up sit down
relax i'll tell you what we're gonna do
you're gonna find out who took our
cocaine
and then i'm gonna kill them
[Music]
moving on
[Music]
passenger show us your hands
stop
get down on your knees
now down on your stomach
there you go
i'll take that hernandez hey that's my
paper man that's money
this is drug money it's my money man hey
don't worry about it i'll fill it out
later
welcome home carl glad to be back
you haven't forgotten about us have you
boy hell no officer 10 penny i was just
wondering what took y'all so long
get in the car
ease up man damn
watch your head
i bet you been carl how's your wonderful
family i'm here to bury my mom's you
know that yeah i guess i do
so what else you got shaking carl
nothing
i live in liberty city now
i'm clean legit
nah you ain't never been clean carl
well what do we got here
this is a weapon officer pulaski that
was used to gun down a police officer
not 10 minutes ago
officer pendlebury a fine man i might
add
you work fast
you know i just got off the plane that's
a good thing we found you we retrieved
the murder weapon that ain't my gun
don't [ __ ] me carl yeah don't
[ __ ] him carl what the [ __ ] you want
from me this time when we want you
we'll fight
in the meantime
try not to gun down any more officers of
the law
y'all can't leave me here this baldness
country
i thought you said you was innocent carl
but you don't bad
58 see you around like a donut carl
officer pendlebury is down
we'll be right up oh [ __ ] here we go
again
worst place in the world rolling heights
baller country
nine represented grove street in five
years but the ballers won't give a [ __ ]
stop it what are you doing carl brian
stop it
quit it moms are here
mom they're up to something
you picked the wrong house fool hey hey
big smoke it's me carl chill chill
cj
oh
my god what's up
baby you okay man nah man it's my mom's
homie
hey i don't know why this had to happen
but i promise you i'm gonna find out who
killed your moms
the streets is cold dawg like it says in
the book we are blessed
and cursed
what [ __ ] book saying things make us
laugh
make us cry
but right now we gotta take care of
business go see your brother at the
cemetery come on let's bounce
no homie love no huh oh for sure for
sure
my bad what's cracking with you hey man
what you strapped for
man some pizza place keeps paying
overall hit up man [ __ ] is beautiful
taste on a lesson from grove street
[Music]
[Music]
like a raggedy ass mother
i'm still on top of my game
what's up
what do you want
have a well-stacked date
[Music]
you